Mysteries of Vernacular.
Bewilder: To confuse or puzzle completely.
The root of the word "bewilder" can be traced back to the Old English word "wilde,"...
...which was used to refer to something that was in a natural state, uncultivated or undomesticated.
Over time, the word "wilde" was often linked to the Old English word "deor."
"Deor," which was derived from an early Indo-European root that meant "breathe,"...
...was initially used to describe any untamed animal or beast.
This eventually morphed into the modern word "deer," meaning a ruminant of the family Cervidae.
The two Old English words when mashed together became "wilderness,"...
...meaning a tract of uncultivated land primarily inhabited by undomesticated beasts.
From the word "wilderness," the word "wilder" was born.
To "wilder" someone was to lead him astray or lure him into the woods.
In the 1600s, the prefix "be," meaning "thoroughly," was compounded with "wilder"...
...as a way of tacking on a little extra punch.
Someone who was "bewildered" was thoroughly lost in the wild.
From this winding background, "bewilder" eventually evolved into our current definition:...
...to be completely confused.